bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 29 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition
le réseau stibus paralysé les salariés
des cars périer qui assurent 60 % du
service des transports ski bus sont
entrés en grève illimitée aujourd'hui
les employés demandent une augmentation
de salaire et une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail
après les attentats survenus à bruxelles
mardi 22 mars les mesures de sécurité
ont été renforcées sur le territoire
français les transports sont devenus la
priorité numéro un
mais peut-on aller encore plus loin dans
la vigilance pour nous en parler ce soir
notre invité julien le cam il est
secrétaire adjoint du syndicat alliance
78 et enfin le premier grand prix de
cyclisme de montigny le bretonneux et
est organisée ce week-end 180 cyclistes
ont fait le déplacement pour participer
à la première édition de la compétition
retour sur l'événement à suivre et jeudi
dernier se dérouler des élections
internes à l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des élections
pour renouveler les membres du conseil
d'administration et des différentes
commissions recherche ou encore vie
universitaire enseignants chercheurs
devaient se prononcer sur des listes et
celle portée par le président sortant
jean luc baissière ne décroche que 20
sièges sur un total de 71 celle soutenue
par son principal opposant didier
guillemot arrive en tête avec 34 sièges
ballottage défavorable dont pour le
président sortant même si rien n'est
encore fait car les étudiants aussi se
sont prononcés dans d'autres commissions
et pour désigner le 10 mai le nouveau
chef de file de l'université il faudra
dompter rassembler on écoute tout de
suite didier guillemot par téléphone il
ya une vraie envie de la communauté
universitaire d'aller de l'avant
voilà c'est à dire que nous avons fait
campagne sur un projet pas du tout sûr à
roger et ce projet qui est assez clair
remporter l'adhésion
je pense que c'est ça que l'on peut dire
à l'issue du scrutin
nous avons fait une campagne mieux
transparente sur un projet avec l'idée
de rassembler et maintenant il va nous
falloir rassembler au delà des
différentes listes parce que c'est de
l'université dont il s'agit et ce
travail commence dès aujourd'hui
je précise que le président sortant
jean-luc vestiaire n'a en revanche pas
encore réagi à ces résultats malgré nos
demandes d'interview conflit social à
présent les salariés des cars périer qui
assurent 60 % du service des transports
qui buses ski bus sont entrés en grève
illimitée
aujourd'hui suite au préavis déposé par
l'intersyndicale cfdt unsa et sud
les employés demandent une augmentation
de salaire et une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail
un reportage signé miquel et demi
d'euros une partie de ski bus étaient à
l'arrêt aujourd'hui une cinquantaine de
chauffeurs de la société des cars périer
à protester devant les grilles de
l'entrepôt attrape des employés qui
assurent 60 % du service des transports
du basson saint quentinois demandent une
augmentation de salaire et une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail
aujourd'hui nous ensemble à arriver à
ces grèves car c'est la direction qui
l'a voulu nous avons voulu à maintes
reprises par de multiples réunions
entamer ce dialogue mais on nous a fait
comprendre clairement que
il y aurait aucune augmentation jusqu'en
2024 on demande 40 euros d'augmentation
histoire de se mettre au même niveau que
les autres sociétés environnantes
on demande une augmentation légitime
suite à quatre ans de vaches maigres
aujourd'hui 92 % des effectifs se sont
mobilisés seulement deux buts sur 10 ont
circulé sur les routes
on s'excuse c'est une de la gêne
occasionnée par cette grève mais bon
c'est une obligation n'a pas d'autre
moyen de communication c'est-à-dire de
moyens d'agir
donc c'est une grève bon c'est vrai que
quand les bus font grève
on touche à un maximum de monde le
trafic devrait être fortement perturbé
au minimum jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
vous avez affaire à des gens très très
déterminée généralement les greffes des
cars périer ça a duré trois semaines
c'est historique chez nous c'est tout le
temps comme ça pas dire quand il ya des
grèves qui sont revendiquées compte des
revendications valable elles durent
longtemps cessé c'est quoi c'est que
c'est normal là aujourd'hui je pense que
les revendications sont légitimes et
réunion devrait être programmée dans les
prochains jours avec la direction les
cars périer transportent quotidiennement
plus de 70 mille voyageurs solliciter
les responsables de l'entreprise vaut
pas souhaité s'exprimer
aujourd'hui mardi 29 mars la
mobilisation du syndicat sud du centre
hospitalier de versailles continue ils
s'étaient donné rendez vous à midi dans
le hall e minute pour une marche en
direction de l'agencé régionale de santé
de versailles les revendications sont
toujours elles mêmes ils dénoncent les
suppressions de plus d'une centaine de
postes programmées par la direction de
l'établissement sur les deux ans à venir
différents types de postes sont menacés
secrétaire aides soignants infirmières
et agents de service hospitalier alors
que l'activité de l'hôpital ne faiblit
pas ces suppressions destinée à
compenser le coût croissant des travaux
de modernisation le centre hospitalier
beaucoup plus cher que prévu
selon le syndicat sud les détails au
micro de sephora mamani aujourd'hui on
peut pas tolérer que le personnel morfle
alors que l'hôpital tourne à plein les
personnels sont épuisées il ya des
burnout enfin des services complets en
burn out et en fait ce qui nous met dans
financièrement c'est les travaux
uniquement les travaux plus le
financement t2a mai
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien mardi dernier la ville de
bruxelles a été frappée par des
attentats terroristes ce sont les
transports publics qui ont été visés
avec l'aéroport de bruxelles et de
stations de métro de la capitale belge
le dernier bilan provisoire fait état de
35 morts et 340 blessés en réaction la
france a pris immédiatement des mesures
pour renforcer la sécurité également
dans les transports publics
pour nous en parler ce soir julien le
cam secrétaire adjoint du syndicat
alliance 78 bonsoir merci à d'être venu
centre bateau pour répondre à nos
questions nous reviendrons sur le sujet
dans quelques instants avant ça je
propose de regarder un reportage donc le
gouvernement français a annoncé que les
mesures de sécurité dans les transports
publics allaient être renforcées dans le
département comme partout en france les
renforcement des patrouilles de
policiers dans le gard est déjà
effective comme à versailles chantiers
ou camille lambert s'est rendu vendredi
dernier regarder
mille six cents policiers gendarmes
supplémentaires pour contrôler les
frontières et les infrastructures de
transport c'est l'annoncé qu'a fait
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur au lendemain des attentats
survenus à bruxelles
les transports sont à présent la
priorité numéro un dans les gares les
contrôles sont renforcés comme à
versailles chantiers où la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
augmente sa visibilité
notre objectif ici dans la guerre des
chantiers c'est à la fois de sécuriser
la zone et d'apporter un petit peu de
d'assurance aux gens qui emploie etc
utilisent les transports en commun
en ce moment je pense que les français
ce qu'ils demandent c'est d'avoir des
policiers dans les gares dans les
transports en commun donc c'est
exactement pour ça qu'on est présent un
peu plus massivement que d'habitude dans
ce genre d'endroits comme après les
attentats survenus à paris en novembre
et en janvier dernier cette présence est
bien accueillie par les usagers des
transports pour des polices et tous les
jours dans les doors tout ça bah oui ça
me rassure parce qu'avec les attentats
qui se passe en ce moment on sait pas ce
qu'il peut se passer par rapport à la
menace qui pèse aujourd'hui sur le pays
c'est plutôt rassurant de voir
effectivement tous ces militaires un
petit peu partout c'est rassurant je
pense que voir les policiers faire leur
travail
pour nous protéger c'est une bonne chose
des équipes supplémentaires qui
s'ajoutent aux cinq mille policiers et
gendarmes déjà mobilisés sur 220 points
de contrôle aux frontières
bernard cazeneuve a demandé à tous les
préfets de renforcer la sécurité
notamment en ile-de-france où 400
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
ont été affectés pour assurer une
vigilance renforcée pansements on fera
attention aux gens qui ont des gros vote
des grosses valises des colis qui
peuvent paraître préparer de manière un
peu particulière
on va pas divulguer les secrets de
fabrique mais c'est évident que le sens
de l'observation du policier est mis à
rude épreuve en ce moment et ce qu'on
demande à nos collaborateurs
c'est de surveiller ce qui se passe le
comportement des passagers et de essayé
d'intercepter celui qui pourrait être un
peu bizarre dans la masse les mesures de
contrôle et de palpation devrait
également s'intensifier
le niveau actuel du plan vigipirate
alerte attentat le plus élevé est
toujours maintenu en ile-de-france alors
je viens de tuer mais on l'a entendu le
reportage 1600 agents sur toute la
france 4 sont en ile de france
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour les
contrôles de sécurité effectivement j'ai
entendu dire de la présence de 400
policiers affectés en ile de france
non nous ont justement dans le 78 il ya
un déficit en fort en termes d'effectifs
il ya eu le renfort manque sur le
week-end dernier deux compagnies de crs
instinct en renfort ponctuel
nous ce qu'on attend c'est des
affectations de fonctionnaires
supplémentaires sur le département
le département est en déficit d'environ
200 250 fonctionnaires de police donc
voila nous attendons des renforts en
effectif et non pas des renforts
ponctuels de crs donc finalement à les
dires de bernard cazeneuve qu'il y aura
plus de deux policiers s'avance et ça se
voit pas sur le terrain non notamment
pour le 78 on voit qu'au mois d'avril il
ya une sortie d'école une promo de
d'école qui sort aucun fonctionnaire
nette affectée pour le 78 je parle pour
les yvelines on a vraiment un problème
d'effectif
on est bien content d'être renforcée
ponctuellement parler nos collègues crs
mais cela ne suffit pas il nous faut des
affectations supplémentaires en sortie
d'école alors c'est de la prévention de
la vigilance il y aura plus de contrôle
mais c'est pas assez d'effectifs
finalement à quoi ça sert alors en plus
il ya une superposition des missions
c'est à dire que en plus de sécuriser
les transports en commun mes collègues
doivent faire des passages devant les
écoles devant les lieux de culte
sensibles devant les sites touristiques
comme le château de versailles comme les
centres commerciaux
un saint quentin en yvelines on voit
vélizy 2 parler d'eux et effectivement
il n'y a pas assez d'effectifs pour
faire toutes ces missions
est-ce que s'appuyait sur les agents de
la sncf la sécurité ça ça peut aider
aussi ça peut être une solution windows
nos collègues de la suge qui sont
également armés s'il pouvait être
renforcée également nous si vous voulez
on est preneurs de toute forme de
renforts comment on voit les militaires
qui sont déployés également mais en
terme d'effectifs policiers
effectivement il ya une inquiétude vous
en parler de cette inquiétude justement
gouvernement vous leur faites tout à
fait tout à fait alliance police
nationale on demande des renforts il ya
actuellement jeu qu il ya environ deux
mois il ya eu un concours exceptionnel
voilà qui est qu'il ya eu je crois être
en 2000 personnes se sont présentées au
concours donc on est content mais
effectivement entre la formation le
temps des concours les renforts se sont
mettre longtemps à arriver
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit justement voilà
le chef de l'état le gouvernement
les solutions pour vous faire patienter
entre les solutions effectivement il ya
un plan bac qui a été mis en place avec
le renfort de fin la dotation de moyens
supplémentaires mais sans effectif
effectivement c'est compliqué
nous on demande également à nyons police
nationale la gratuité des transports
pour les fonctionnaires de police qui
ont le droit depuis la mise en place de
l'état d'urgence à porter leurs armes
hors service cette gratuité dans les
transports publics permettraient de
sécuriser les transports voilà le
policier
prendrait les transports pour se rendre
au travail pour se déplacer
effectivement ce serait une manière de
sécuriser les transports c'est une
revendication de son syndicat
nous avons été mobilisés d'ailleurs il
ya une dizaine de jours devant les
locaux de la sncf à saint-denis et pour
demander cette cette parité avec les
gendarmes les gendarmes on l'est on sait
gratuité dans les transports
alors il ya peu de temps avant les
attentats qui sont survenus à bruxelles
au niveau des taux maximum a été
prolongée en france et les syndicats de
police mais que c'était vraiment
compliqué justement pour les roulements
qu'il y avait encore pas suffisamment de
personnel a exactement en fin de compte
comme je les dis superposition des
missions les collègues et une
restriction en termes de congé ce qui en
fait il y a beaucoup d'annulations en
termes de vacances donc les
fonctionnaires ne se repose pas il y à
une accumulation des démissions des
rappels au service des heures
supplémentaires est effectivement du
coup ce qui entraîne de la fatigue
voilà ce qui est un très inquiétant
finalement voilà on doit s'inquiéter les
citoyens français doivent s'inquiéter 7
ce qui n ont pas ce que vous avez à
faire à une police très bien formés très
professionnel mais effectivement nous on
demande à nos responsables à notre
ministre monsieur cazeneuve et et
comment au chef du gouvernement de nous
de nous aider nous s'attribuer des
effectifs supplémentaires
la priorité numéro 1 maintenant ce sont
les transports avec ce qui est survenu à
bruxelles même si les moyens ont été
renforcés c'est quand même très ça
paraît très compliqué de pouvoir
sécuriser les métros les gars est
possible de vraiment alors il y à mille
fonctionnaires qui sont spécialisés dans
la sécurisation des transports en commun
pour toute la région ile de france
effectivement si
si vous faites le service 7 jours sur 7
24 sur 24 du coup c'est mille
fonctionnaires là à l'instant t
voilà ça fait pas assez de
fonctionnaires pour sécuriser ils ont le
même problème j'ai pris contact avec mes
homologues parisiens qui m'ont dit la
même chose en manque d'effectif criant
est effectivement de tout sécurisé c'est
impossible
la sncf parle de mettre en avant enfin
de construire des portiques pour
sécuriser est-ce que ça ce serait une
solution mais ça mettra peut-être trop
temps à venir
oui alors c'est une solution
sensibiliser les gens également voilà
sensibiliser le public qui n'hésite pas
à faire 17 en cas de présence de
rencontre 1 constatation d'un colligées
suspect de faire le 17
effectivement c'est c'est une solution
les portiques après c'est une question
de moyens je pense donc c'est compliqué
de poser des portiques à toutes les
gares alors les messages de vigilance et
de prévention à destination va des
citoyens français se multiplient est-ce
que vous dont ils doivent être plus
mobilisée pour vraiment savoir comment
agir en cas d'attentât comme ce qui
s'est passé à paris mais aussi à
bruxelles
à bâle la première des choses
effectivement c'est de composer le 17 ou
de faire le 112 ne pas hésiter à
signaler qu un comportement suspect
comme disait monsieur ghosn fondant dans
le reportage qui ne faut pas hésiter à
faire 17 pour signaler un colis suspect
un comportement suspect voilà mes
intervenir là également
non je pense que danser dans ces cas-là
déjà de composer nous d'appeler la
police est déjà une bonne chose ou de
signaler un agent sncf un comportement
suspect de se retourner vers des
professionnels comme il ya des
formations aux premiers secours est ce
qu'il pourrait avoir des formations
comment agir en cas d'attaqué terroriste
peut-être pour que les citoyens supplée
au pouvoir de police alors le mois
j'inviterai plus tôt et citoyen je vous
dise c'est très compliqué de d'inviter
les citoyens à faire face à des
terroristes je pense que d'être vigilant
faire 17 les scellés
la police à intervenir ou les
fonctionnaires de la suge pour la sncf
où les militaires voilà je pense qu'il
ya quand même dans les grandes gares de
la présence de beaucoup d'agents et je
pense que ne pas intervenir et faire
appel aux professionnels
alors les transports sont en ce moment
une priorité mais dans les églises vrai
qu'on a beaucoup de centres commerciaux
ont investi le château de versailles un
site très visité les efforts sont
maintenus également est-ce que ça va
être un petit peu délaissé au profit
justement non justement alors voilà
c'est là que c'est très compliqué pour
mes collègues qui en plus de sécuriser
donc il ya une multitude de de servitude
qui qui superpose effectivement les
effectifs ne sont pas assez nombreux
pour faire toutes les missions alors ils
le font comme ils peuvent
voilà mais il faudrait du renfort
d'effectifs pour effectuer la
sécurisation de tous les sites sensibles
et tous les lieux publics
vous représentez le syndicat allemand de
la police environ soit 71 que les
militaires pourraient venir prêter
main-forte est ce que ce serait
envisageable parce que vous vous
demandez ça également on le voit déjà la
joie en passant devant la gare de
saint-quentin j'ai vu quatre militaires
avec leur famas devant la gare ce qui
est une bonne chose nous je vous dis
renfort de militaires pour pourquoi pas
cessé leurs rôles de de nous rassurer de
sécuriser eu également les transports
pourquoi pas mais l'utilisation est ce
qu'il ya des efforts des forces de
sécurité peut-être penser à des
militaires qui sont en opération
extérieure on revient de règlement pour
assurer des missions de sécurité
intérieure c'est quelque chose qui me
qui me dépasse un peu un mois je peux
vous dire je suis comme je suis un
citoyen ventoux est effectivement de
croiser des policiers ça me rassure des
gendarmes des militaires
voilà c'est pourquoi pas c est peut-être
en visitant le visage en visage et reza
pardon je sais pas on parle de plus en
plus de l'armement des policiers
municipaux
ça c'est quelque chose pour lequel vous
vous militez encore vraiment une
solution oui oui avec une formation
adéquate les fonds que fin mai
de la police municipale sont à même de
porter des armes d'ailleurs beaucoup de
communes le font actuellement
nous on est on est pour ce déploiement
effectivement de d'armes l'armement des
polices municipales peut-être élargir ça
va peut-être aidé des personnes de la
sécurité dans les centres commerciaux
des vigiles lui plus réservé s'il ya une
formation si pourquoi pas vous savez
d'être doté d'une arme nécessite une
formation nécessite oui toute une
logistique de stockage de transport de
larmes
pourquoi pas si les moyens sont là
pourquoi pas une dernière question avant
de terminer cet entretien on l'a vu dans
le reportage
donc il faut faire attention au valais
ce que valises au colis suspect vous
avez peut-être des conseils à donner
voilà aux citoyens qui seraient
peut-être vu qu'il verrait ce genre de
choses comment réagir à ce moment là
déjà d'établir un périmètre espions
d'établir un périmètre de sécurité et je
vous dit se retourner vers le
professionnel sncf militer un premier
policier qui est de composer le 17 ou le
112 tout de suite effectivement de
davies et les gens aux alentours et de
faire un père et un premier périmètre et
de se retourner vers un professionnel et
c'est vraiment devoir de chacun d'être
vigilant papier oui oui oui merci
beaucoup je viens d'avoir répondu à
notre à nos questions il est devenu sur
notre plateau fin on passe maintenant à
une page sportive il y avait du cyclisme
ce dimanche matin à montigny le
bretonneux le premier grand prix de la
ville saint-quentinoise était organisée
au départ de l'avenue du parc 180
cyclistes ont fait le déplacement pour
participer à la compétition un reportage
signé michael et minéraux une première
réussie le premier grand prix de
montigny-le-bretonneux réunis ce
dimanche plus de 180 cyclistes venus
principalement d'île de france
les sportifs répartis dans deux courses
de catégorie d3 d4 et d1 d2 se sont
affrontés sur une boucle de 3 km au
départ de l'avenue du parc circulent en
ville mais avec l' avantage
quand même de développer trois
kilomètres et puis d'être à la fois pas
dangereux tout en pouvant être sélectif
mais tout le monde a sa chance sur un
circuit comme ça il faut pas
spécialement et du grimpeur faut pas
spécialement si t'es un homme fort qui
peut gagner c'est tout un bon parcours
c'est roulant il ya pas mal de relances
dans la catégorie d3 d4 thierry lebon
champion de france des sapeurs pompiers
licencié au vélo club des miroirs
remporter la course
tu as une petite touche particulière
parce qu'en tant qu'ancien unis montrent
un j'ai travaillé neuf ans ensemble de
secours de montigny donc j'avais à coeur
de venir ici et de faire quelque chose
objectif rempli et il fallut lancé le
sprint de très loin dans le vent pour
arriver à ses fins lors de la deuxième
course benjamins cresson d'orsay a
devancé au sprint
yoann udry de l'ue et small and hove
étiez du club de montigny termine lui à
une belle quatrième place
une deuxième édition du grand prix
devraient être organisées en 2017 ou
poweo à harry du coup on a joué des
coudes sur les tatamis de guyancourt ce
week-end un tournoi pour les petits
judokas était organisé au gymnase
maurice baquet cette compétition amicale
était destiné aux enfants âgés de 5 à 9
ans les a produits notions vues
dénombrés à cette occasion les prises de
judo et les codes de ce sport on écoute
le président du club
c'est une petite compétition qui nous
sert en fait à montrer aux enfants
comment se déroule une compétition
comment on peut faire déjà un peu
d'arbitrage ça nous sert aussi pour les
adolescents donc de commencer
l'arbitrage et puis d'avoir des notions
d'arbitrage
et puis voilà c'est quoi ton inhérents
au judo d'avoir des parties de
compétition pour pour les entraîner un
mot de baseball à présent les couillard
de montigny-le-bretonneux ont remporté
ce week-end la 20e édition du tournoi de
pâques au stade jean maréchal une
compétition amicale organisée chaque
année pour préparer l'équipe en vue du
championnat
un reportage signé mickaël mille euros
c'est désormais une tradition pour la
vingtième année consécutive les cougars
de montigny-le-bretonneux ont organisé
ce week-end le retour note bac 2 au
stade jean maréchal les fans de baseball
saint quentinois ont pu voir leurs
protégés mais également les gee moeurs
de saint lô les sense de saint-jean
mansle et les outlaws de strasbourg
cette année c'est plus un niveau
régional national une donc un petit peu
en dessous de notre division mais ça
reste quand même un niveau correct pour
pouvoir se préparer de bonnes façons le
tournoi de pâques bien qu'amical est
avant tout un rendez-vous pour permettre
aux cougars de préparer le championnat
de deuxième division la saison débutera
le dimanche 3 avril sur le terrain
dissin l'intérêt du tournoi c'est aussi
de faire pas mal de matchs donc de bien
se préparer avant la saison prendre
pendant bas de voir des lanceurs d'avoir
du temps de jeu pour arriver en pleine
forme la semaine prochaine ces deux
jours ont également permis au public
d'apercevoir la nouvelle recrue
américaine ryan juares annonceurs
d'origine californienne qui a évolué en
l'australie la saison dernière le
sportif devrait être l'une des têtes
d'affiché de l'équipe cette année là
c'est marrant pour celui là on voit
vraiment qu'il est agressif dans le jeu
et c'est ça qui fait plaisir
après il a vraiment le style américain
vraiment joué le jeu ça qui est marrant
il a bien lancé le premier match et un
10 0
la semaine dernière à montpellier l'a
réalisé une bonne performance contre une
équipe de notre division donc on est
vraiment confiant avec lui sur
denticules les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux ont remporté le tournoi de
pâques en battant en finale les sense de
sergio anglais et vous savez ce week-end
c'était le week-end de pâques nous
n'allons pas nous quitter
avant un mot de chocolat samedi dernier
donc pour ce week-end la ville
d'elancourt organisé la traditionnelle
chasse aux oeufs plus d'un millier
d'enfants de 3 à 11 ans étaient au parc
des coudrais pour remplir leurs paniers
de chocolat williams elle à chercher les
oeufs avec le regarder a il encourt le
week-end dernier le faire que des
coudrais a pris l'alluré d'un grand
magasin un jour de soldes pris d'assaut
par 1500 enfants élan courtois venu
participer à la grande chasse aux oeufs
c'est une chasse aux oeufs ou
on a distribué six mille the sur tout le
parc des coudrais 1,9 égale un oeuf en
chocolat en échange et nous avons 50 de
l'eau donc 52e numérotés et ils viennent
les échanges et ici on a des places de 6
d
des places pour france miniature
beaucoup de chocolat une chasse qui
prend parfois des allures de course seul
objectif aujourd'hui ramasser un maximum
de en plastique pour venir ensuite les
échanger contre de véritables the en
chocolat récolte est bonne on prend le
thé et le polystyrène et on vient d
échanger contre des heures chocolat
l'expliquer c'était un petit peu sport
avec une petite fille de 3 ans il
fallait se jeter dans la foule pourquoi
aller chercher les oeufs mais non non
c'est un bon moment en famille
ici pas de perdant tout le monde a eu
droit à du chocolat
une deuxième édition pour une chasse aux
oeufs qui a su rassembler comme un
échauffement pour les enfants avant que
le lapin de pâques passe dans leur
jardin
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
retrouver nicolas kirillovitch pour le
7-8 société il vous parlera avec ses
invités du sidaction qui a lieu ce
week-end c'est la fin à présent de cette
édition je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée vous retrouve demain pour un
nouveau journal à revoir